foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
I'm Piers Morgan uncensored tonight she
was simply the best breaking news Tina
Turner has died at the age of 83 will
pay tribute to one of the all-time music
greats plus he's the social media
so-called pranksters but National
outrage by terrorizing innocent
bystanders mizzy as he calls himself
enter people's homes without permission
stole property not people off their
bikes even stolen elderly woman's dog or
for social media Fame on Tick Tock today
he got away with a 365 pound fine many
think that's not enough he joins me live
and Michael block is the underdog hero
who electrified the sporting world this
week and punctured our Collective Doom
and Gloom with a winning attitude to
living a dream the Rocky Balboa of golf
joins me live to tell me how he did it
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored well
good evening from London welcome to
Piers Morgan on censored uh sad breaking
news at the start of the show this
evening the legendary Tina Turner has
died at the age of 83 one of the
all-time music greats simply as she's
sang the best and will pay tribute to
her a little later in the program but
first many young people see social media
stardom as a fast track to Fame and
Fortune people you've never heard of can
become very famous and very wealthy very
quickly from the business of bagging
clicks and followers online but with
more than 500 hours of content uploaded
every single minute just to YouTube how
do they even begin to get noticed well
some influencers have a talent they can
sing or dance some give Brash opinions
some play computer games some give
friendly tutorials on things like how to
do makeup or make music but others get
their clicks by honestly behaving like
complete morons in California a YouTuber
and pilot faced 20 years in jail for
crashing an airplane to get more
subscribers others have jumped from City
buildings taken on wild animals crash
cars you name it have a mad at it if
someone has tried it just for the clicks
an order in the name of becoming
insta-famous this week of social media
prankster named Missy has generated
headlines and abject outrage for
so-called pranks which mostly involved
just terrorizing innocent bystanders
James
hello we've got a nice dog
a lot of times
[Music]
what does public anger grew this week
London's met police announced they were
looking for Missy real name bakari
bronzagaro the lord caught up with him
and today it was fine 365 pounds and
given a criminal Behavior order which is
supposed to ban him from posting to
social media without the written
permission of the people in his videos
you might think that's not much of a
punishment or much of a deterrent what
does he think well fresh from the
courtroom he's here now all right well
good evening to you hello hello players
long time no see it's been a long time
no see last time I caught on your thing
with my friend
that's right you're paid in the
background yeah
okay well I'm not your mate um what I am
as an interviewer I'm curious about what
has been motivated you to terrorize the
people around where you live I wouldn't
really call it terrorizing I'll just
call it more having fun but let's get
this out of the way first I apologize
you see this situation I blew up on the
Internet they're walking into random
houses
the next day I apologize to the woman
because I felt bad in it like deep in a
social media like it went deeper than
social media that's why I didn't record
it she recorded me apologizing to her I
told her sorry and she explained that
she was terrified because like children
were in the house and I understand what
are they doing in the house
was a dean in the house I don't know it
was a stupid video like I got peer
pressure to see I want to say it like in
that way but somebody else is full I
don't blame you on no one else when
you're breaking that house with it with
a with a woman and a husband
no I'm just saying okay you went through
their door right but it's not your house
you're not supposed to be in there oh no
you are causing a lot of alarm to that
poor woman and to her children who are
in the house you then terrorize this
poor elderly woman and take a dog away
and traumatize her oh the story about
that hang on hang on because
don't just keep talking like an idiot
right right don't let me finish what the
viewers don't know you did all right you
go up and you do these things you take a
dog from an elderly woman you Leap Frog
over the top of an Orthodox Jewish man
standing at the side of the road minding
his own business you go up to women in
the street and say do you want to die it
wasn't a woman it was a man and she
there were also women
there but I only say it to their man
right you shouldn't be saying it to
anybody fair enough why are you why in
the name of so-called prankster humor
why cause so much alarm and distress to
so many people do you get your kicks out
of doing that not necessarily but you
can say that this whole public outro
just makes me laugh because people are
getting hurt over something that didn't
happen to them and that's how I see us
what do you mean people are getting hurt
over something that didn't happen to
them everyone acts like they have this
Persona like they don't care Oh social
media is a facilities than the other but
when me comes out and does the Mad thing
everyone has something so it's a bad
thing it's the Mad thing you already you
already said it was dramatics no it's
not mad it's moronic it's the kind of
thing anybody could do and you do it for
kicks and you do it for clicks and you
get your little moment on Tick Tock and
presumably your peer group that you
referenced earlier they all say good on
you good on you missy this is hilarious
meanwhile some poor woman thinks you've
stolen her dog and is traumatized
another woman has her two kids and
you're bursting into their house
Uninvited all right you're jumping on
Jewish people yeah
people hold up
you did cool it was a Jewish person cool
but there was a trend going around a
tick tock called free oh oh I've done
this to numerous people black people
white people age any types of people I
don't discriminate so don't stop saying
Orthodox Jewish person like I only
targeted him and was only him that I
went for why are you targeting anybody
in that what would you mean why am I
targeting anyone it was a trend it was a
trend I just done it for a trend what's
the trend what's the trend free or oh
jump over someone at the time of the
beat however much you scare them how
however I'm actually scared or even if
you pushed him into a car no that's that
that didn't happen because I saw it
didn't happen but it didn't happen but
it didn't happen a lot of the stuff that
you do could have consequences far more
serious but you don't care do you as
long as you get a lot I have remorse I
have remorsefulness
do you live in my life are you there for
my parents have you been there what's
your life tell me you told me my life
presumably are you about life you're
assuming you're about to tell me the sob
story what's the sub story what's your
story about what's so bad about your
life in it I I
I just do it for fun on the off camera I
do my team tell me about your life what
justifies this what's happened to you
that makes you think you're justified in
doing this would you tell me about my
life well you said you said you did
anything about your life tell me about
yourself you're trying to get on to you
because I'm black because I guarantee
you because you're black yeah I
guarantee if I don't give a damn about
your skin color really no who cares why
would I care of what color your skin is
I just think you're an idiot oh thank
you I think you're idiot too that's fine
you're perfectly entitled to yeah it's
about you so the show's called
uncensored I think you're an idiot for
what you've been doing I also think
you're an idiot for playing the race car
when no one's mentioned your skin color
really okay you don't have to mention it
to her I don't care about your skin
color
care about the fact that you've been
terrorizing all these people for a
sustained period of time I also care
about the fact you've only got a tiny
fine today no deterrent to you
whatsoever you don't show any real
remorse you don't really care it is you
can lose a week simple as the UK laws
are weak simple as and that's not my
fault that's not my fault like what's
your fan what's your family make of what
you've been doing
ah what did my family meet well I don't
chat to my mum anymore and why not why
not because I just don't talk to us
relevant to you but I just don't chat to
her in it and what else my sisters are
calm but like obviously they don't fully
comment what I do but when did your
family condemn what you do no of course
not like obviously they think it's all
perfectly normal no there's certain
videos that they'll be like no you can't
be doing that like especially just
walking into the random house is one
certainly not but that was more of a
spur of the moment thing I've got egg
done and my ego got a hold of me and I
realized that at that moment and that's
why I went to apologize the next day
after this who blew a part of proportion
and I felt like bad personally I don't
think you felt that okay well you I
think you felt that you can see that I
think he felt bad
talking I'm talking I'm talking I'm
talking I'm talking I'm talking it's
fine I'm talking to carry on being an
idiot okay okay we are standing
districts every time I'm actually not
going to call you missy it's obviously a
stage I'll call you bakari bronze right
all right becoming bronze let's try and
talk to each other as human beings all
right all right yeah I'm trying to
understand
why there's no real remorse here
what do you mean there's a consequences
or apologize off social media I could
have recorded that apology and that
would have been another viral video
whether it's hate or whatever literally
hate brings money hate brings lacks
hates brings views it doesn't matter
level hate it still brings views why why
do you prefer to do the hateful stuff
not like how perfectly the hateful stuff
it's just like it's easier to do the
hateful what are you laughing obviously
I don't think it's fun but you're a
funny person you do think it's funny
you're a funny person you do I've seen
the videos you do you think it's just
really fun at the time I think it's
funny my fan base thinks it's funny and
it's we outside in it it's a movement
but what's something deep down what's
the movie deep down being free and not
letting anyone tell you nothing that's
why I can do all of this stuff I have
I'm the most hated person on the
internet right now
who you are okay then whatever you say
in it whatever you say most people
watches will have never heard of you oh
now they are that you just put it to me
they'll just look at the way you're
behaving now and I think yeah he's a
complete all right
is it because I'm black is it somehow
why are you going back to that I said
that once Yeah you mentioned it I
mentioned it once again your skin color
all right cool God I don't care what
color you are all right if you were
white I'd have exactly the same view
about your moronic Behavior right but
I'm curious who in your family is there
to tell you this why do you need to go
to my family I'm my own personal talk
about music
because you don't talk about me not my
family yes but here's the problem what's
the problem you are clearly a product of
your upbringing no I'm not I'm my own
person I've always been my own person
you've had no one to tell you this is
wrong of course people have told me it's
wrong family friends everyone's told me
who sold you what do you mean my own
mother told me this wrong there's been
situations between me and my wife right
so your mother doesn't like what you're
doing yeah
so why don't you stop doing it because
my mother told me to stop doing
something okay you listen to your mother
you listen to somebody else I'm my own
person I'm I'm legally I don't know so I
can do I what are you going to do now
what am I going to do now
Twitter all Missy is banned and I'm
gonna be on Twitch yeah I'm gonna start
streaming on Twitch IRL streams gaming
streams my twitch is busy as live if you
want to get that but yeah I do want to
try and come up with a sincere apology
or not no I don't need to come up with
no sincere apology I already had my own
remorse and I already I already what do
you mean okay then whatever you it's all
a bit of a joke and if you steal some
old woman's dog it's all a bit of fun if
you jump on a Jewish man it's all a bit
of fun if you run into people's houses
with young kids and terrorizers it's all
a bit of fun but what I'm saying is
nothing really massive what I'm saying
to you is there's been plans to change
up everything can you you let us know
jalapeno you just talk your own thing
you have your own set morals and yeah so
that's you no it's not about morality
okay cool cool
still talking I'm still talking
interrupting again again
why'd you keep interrupting let me tell
you we're gonna put both of ourselves
out of this misery and we'll just end it
there because you should end as I said
at the start you're just a complete
heartwarming story The Rocky Balboa of
golf Michael Block's story has inspired
the world unlike this and he'll be we'll
be next to him
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no what
are you every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it well
that one too
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to Piers Morgan uncensible
a few days ago I opened this show by
saying that in a world of moaning and
groaning whining and wailing sulking and
complaining we should all be a little
bit more like Michael block he's the 46
year old dad and local golf club pro who
just lit up one of golf's major
tournaments in spectacular fashion
through sheer force of will he made the
cut at a major PGA tournament for the
first time last week where he
electrified the crowds huge crowds that
came for him by the end paired with
Superstar Rory McIlroy and then dunked a
ridiculously improbable hole in one that
will be replayed for years to come along
the way he Charmed and delighted
Millions with his humility his humor his
emotion and his can-do spirit and we now
know a little bit more about how he did
it and why we should indeed all be a
little bit more like Michael block it
boils down to two short phrases and four
words firstly scrawled on his golf balls
are the words why not that's what he
once said to his caddy who just told him
he was one pot away a 22 foot putt from
making the U.S open and he nailed it
because why not secondly his son Dylan
has caddy for him in the past apparently
did something simple but extraordinary
when Block's confidence was seriously
flagging a few years ago he said look
inside your shoes Dad and when block did
he saw the words don't quit
I love that some people might think I've
lost my marbles for banging on about a
golfer all week but for me it's not
about golf it's not even really about
sport it's about being a human being
who's had a dream all his life and when
he got the chance to realize that dream
he grabbed it by the Scruff of the neck
I called in the Rocky Balboa of golf for
exactly that reason and I never missed
an opportunity to play the Piers Morgan
mantra for winning not whining spoken by
the man himself
let me tell you something you already
know
the world ain't all sunshine and
rainbows it's a very mean and nasty
place and I don't care how tough you are
it will beat you to your knees and keep
you there permanently if you let it you
me or nobody is going to hit as hard as
life
but it ain't about how hard you hit it's
about how hard you can get hit and keep
moving forward how much you can take and
keep moving forward
that's how when it is done
well no one personifies that Spirit more
than my next guest if that doesn't get
you moving nothing will right ironically
what my producers told me that Michael
block was unavailable for interview on
Monday I had two short phrases for them
why not don't quit so I'm delighted to
say Michael block now joins me live from
the Colonial Country Club in Texas
Michael uh a great honor to have you on
Piers Morgan on Saturday I want to start
by an admission until last week I'd
never heard of you
um like probably most people who watched
you and then by the end of the week the
whole of America near you the whole
world near you and you had endeared
yourself to tens of millions of people
around the world
how do you feel what's it been like to
be Michael Block in the last few days
it's probably Pierce uh I mean you know
how it feels but
for us average folks like me uh yeah
it's exactly what you would think your
brain just is numb uh it's insane you
can't comprehend what's even going on uh
it's nuts I'm literally just floating
around at this point and thank God I've
got a whole bunch of people here helping
me get through it and uh
I got a couple more interviews and then
uh I'm gonna I'm gonna get my my clubs
back out I'm gonna practice all
afternoon get ready for tomorrow's uh
tournament that was uh this is one of
the great benefits already you're being
invited to take part in in tournaments
which you wouldn't otherwise have been
playing in otherwise you'd have been
back at your local club uh teaching
people how to play this game that you
you love you're 46 years old and you've
had this Burning dream for so long
to actually realize that dream to
compete against the very best in one of
the great major tournaments and then to
drain that ludicrous hole in one where
you didn't even need the ball to bounce
like the rest of us or go along the
ground like the rest of us it just went
straight in the hole with Rory McIlroy
hagging you thousands of Spectators
going nuts Millions watching at home
going nuts that moment I mean is that
the dream realized for you whatever
happens next
you know I mean I've been playing
tournament golf for my goodness 40 years
I've never had a hole in one in a
tournament in my life and for the ball
to go directly into the hole is it was
almost like somebody just grabbed it out
of the air and threw it into the hole uh
under those circumstances it's
unbelievable and I guess that's why the
stories is what it is I mean I couldn't
have asked for a better timing of making
a shot in my entire life and it happened
under those circumstances playing with
one of my Idols Rory McIlroy playing
front of the Rochester New York fans who
were absolutely behind me a hundred
percent uh and I wasn't even thinking
about the millions of people behind all
the cameras I was just sitting there
wanting to let that crowd go absolutely
crazy and I guess I did exactly what I
needed to do on that hole you sowed so
much emotion throughout the whole
process of this tournament and yet your
wife has said that you never cried when
your kids were born when your two sons
or you're a very loving dad and they're
both very good young golfers you never
cried when they were born but you've
been weeping away for the last four days
how do you explain you find this more
emotional
oh boy
um
you could say I love the game of golf uh
unbelievably but
um I mean obviously I love my kids more
I love a lot of things more than golf
but golf is just this passion and it's a
sport and the only time I had ever cried
ever before I started crying about my
own game was watching Rudy and watching
the movie Rudy and when he puts that you
know the all the all the teammates come
in and put their jerseys down so Rudy
can play yeah that's the only other time
I remember ever having that emotional
state and actually coming to tears and
so now it's I feel like that every time
I hear somebody tell me these uh items
like I know I idea that I was in the
next PGA Championship or how much I won
or what other tournaments I got into and
every single time I hear these great
things uh it just brings me to tears and
uh it's it's been amazing and I am
definitely an emotional roller coaster I
know I mean one of the most
extraordinary of all the remarkable
moments you've had is that you've got to
think three or four thousand text
messages and you were told by somebody
from Nike look you better check them
because in the middle of them is one
from Michael Jordan who'd seen you were
wearing a pair of his sneakers
um have you found that text and what did
he say to you
the second that I got the word I go you
what I go Michael texted me I'm like I
didn't see it and they're like you're
kidding me I'm like no and so I just
started scrolling and scrolling and I've
literally thousands upon thousands of
texts and half of them don't have a name
and I definitely didn't have his name in
my contacts so I kept on scrolling
finally found it and he basically said
something down to the lines that uh this
is why he loves the game of golf so much
and uh my big request from him is that I
want to spend one of those days with him
at his course and play 36 holes with him
and his friends and that just that just
will make my life complete I mean
Michael Jordan it's for many the
greatest athlete to ever play any sport
to be taking time out of his his life to
text you Michael block uh that's a
remarkable thing right
uh
uh I don't think uh you know outside of
my friends and family nobody ever texted
me before last week so yeah having
Michael Jordan and all the other texts
I've had since then it's ridiculously
fun and exciting and very very surreal
what does your wife say about this I
mean she's being say behind every great
man is a greater woman she's lived this
dream with you I guess vicariously
through the good and bad often bad I
guess uh often tough certainly it's not
easy to be a journeyman professional
golfer how important has she been to you
unbelievable she's been uh she's been
there for me all the way uh she stood by
me you know when I was making eight
dollars and fifty cents when I started
my job uh and I always said trust me
honey trust me I'm always going to have
you covered uh ever since then and I've
that's been always my goal right to be
able to raise my family in a in a great
spot in southern Orange County and in
California which is isn't easy and uh
it's been huge and she's just a rock for
me
um and she understands what I've been
through the good and the bad and uh she
is she's going to come in hopefully
Saturday here to uh Fort Worth I just
have to make the cut what did your boys
say because I know at least one of them
often carries for you it didn't on this
occasion what did they make of this
their dad their hero suddenly becoming
the world's hero
I've never you know
I've never heard my oldest one say so
many positive things about me usually
you know I was always the enemy and the
and the uh you know the guy that he was
trying to beat on the golf course and
you know my youngest one Ethan he's he's
a sweetheart he's always been the same
way but now all of a sudden Dylan's
chimed in and and he thinks dad's pretty
cool now so uh it's pretty awesome you
know it's pretty awesome as a father
that has a 16 and 18 year old boys uh
for them to look up to their pops is uh
is really awesome and I haven't seen him
since I had not I've not seen him for
one second so I can't wait to be back in
California here in the Whatever It Is by
hopefully Sunday night and uh give them
big hugs Dylan of course was cutting for
you when you had a low moment I think in
2018 you're feeling low about your game
and he said look in your shoes Dad and
it just said the words don't quit how
important was that moment to you
he was 13 years old I just made a triple
bogey I had to finish in the top 20 of
that tournament to get into the PGA
Championship in 2018 at Bellerive
Country Club in St Louis I grew up a
mile from Bell Reef Country Club so it
was my number one priority checklist to
make happen so I'm walking off this hole
just making a horrible mess of it triple
bogey and I'm walking off he's 13. he's
like this this High raise a little guy
and and he says Hey Dad he goes dad did
you look in your shoes and um I'm like
no buddy I just got these last week and
uh because he goes it says don't quit so
you're not going to quit on me and I I
mean I I got emotional at that point too
and I'm like my kids saying it to me I
mean come on let's go and I I've
refocused and I got into a playoff I
made a birdie in the playoff and I got
into the PGA Championship in 2018 which
is which was Unreal it's amazing and it
was also amazing that your golf balls
have the words why not and the story is
great where you're qualifying for the US
opening a 22 foot pot why not is what
you and your caddy you said why not why
shouldn't I get this in and you had the
same attitude actually I watched the
interviews as you progressed in the PGA
tournament you just kept thinking rather
than downplaying the fact you were there
you said well why shouldn't I be here
I'm a professional golfer on my day I
can compete with these guys but to
actually then compete with these guys at
their level to be with Rory McIlroy and
play as well as he did on that final day
that that for you as a golfer what a
moment
I'll tell you what uh everyone should
live that way you know whether it's
going to a business meeting or a sport
or going to your softball game or
whatever it might be I mean if you live
without Mantra why can't it happen to me
uh it's gonna work it's a positive you
know one of the biggest things for me is
to take the negatives out of the uh out
of the brain and replace them with
positive so if I'm thinking positively I
can't think about two things at the same
time so I'm going to keep focusing on
that and that's worked out beautifully
for me
um so I keep that Mantra going and I
kept it going last week I'm Gonna Keep
it going this week and hopefully the
rest of my life and I'm trying to teach
my boys to do the same thing and for
people watching this who have their own
dream whatever it is not necessarily
goals just a dream in life
you've you've realized your dream at 46
where many may have given up hope what
is your message to people living a dream
of any age
given what you've just achieved
well if you're passionate about it and
you work as hard as you possibly can
you're going to give yourself the best
opportunity to have it happen is it a
guaranteed to have happen absolutely not
but at the end of the day
you know when when you're you're about
to leave this this planet
um you can look back at it and you said
I gave it 100 because the last thing I'm
going to do is leave this planet
thinking I only gave it 60 or hey you
know maybe I'm maybe I'm just too tired
I'm gonna go home and relax now go out
play that extra nine go out practice a
little harder go work on that you know
presentation you're going to give the
next day a little harder give it that
extra 100 and uh when it's all said and
done you'll be way happier about it for
yourself
finally Michael uh it's traditional of
course whoever gets a hole in one in
golf buys everybody in the clubhouse a
drink and in fact Brooks kepco won the
tournament when he saw you went I hear
the beers are on you buddy or worse of
that effect when you go back to your
Club will you be buying everybody in
that Clubhouse he'll be going nuts on
your behalf watching their Pro take the
PGA by storm you're going to go back and
buy them all a drink
100 thanks Pierce for saying that you
know they're going to take me for sure
up on that now so yeah I will I will as
long as they were in there for that you
know when they were going nuts when that
hole in one everybody that was in there
at that point without a doubt drinks are
on me when I get back
and just to clarify the moment you knew
you'd got that hole in one
Better Than Sex Michael
[Laughter]
absolutely not
you thought about that I don't even saw
that's a genuine answer but you thought
your wife's watching this didn't you be
honest
you're horrible that was great though
I'm gonna get some for that you are are
you you eventually you managed to get
the right right answer out what did Rory
McIlroy say to you just finally because
you were playing with this great guy he
was so moved I think by the whole
experience he said you have bigger
crowds following you than him and he
hugged you at the end what did he say to
you
oh he was he was uh instrumental uh how
sweet he was and how nice he was to me
the entire time took me under his wing
as did Rosie on Saturday uh that was
huge
um that's probably one of the reasons I
was able to shoot a 71 that final round
and and have that stuff happen but uh he
just said keep it going just be you
that's what I kept in here from a lot of
the guys just be you keep keep doing
what you're doing and that's what I'm
gonna do I'm just trying to be me still
I'm out here in in Texas now I'm gonna
do the exact same thing I did last week
does that guarantee that I'm gonna have
a hole in one or finish 15th absolutely
not but you guys all know that at the
end of the day that when I leave here
and when I leave Texas go back to
California I gave it everything I had
Michael you're fantastic honestly I
loved the interviews through the
progress of that tournament I loved the
hole in one I love the magic of it all I
love the hope and inspiration you've
given every golfer like me in the world
playing around off 16 and hoping that
one day maybe we could do what you did
you lived a dream for a lot of us a lot
of Pros a lot of everyone actually
living a dream out there thank you for
that and congratulations honestly it's
one of the great Sports stories of
recent years and I I loved every second
of it
hey Pierce thank you so much and uh
thanks for having me on
good to see you
well it says the next two British police
be a little more German when taking on
eco Warriors who try to shut down our
roads and public transport and debate
that with the please pack next
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember a if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
we don't have any fancy speech writers
here but we do and I promise you discuss
the issues that matter to you yes I'm
back talk TV not with Morgan just before
him Monday to Thursday at 7pm join me
just do it well that one too
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back to Facebook organization a
game of two halves this evening when it
comes to our interview guest talking
contributor Esther Krakow is here the
mirrors Associated to Kevin McBride
talking to your presenter Rosanna
Lockwood or welcome to all three of you
yeah a game of two halves Kevin perhaps
the best and the worst of humanity so
far dragged out for the delectation of
our viewers uh look start with this kid
mizzy The Tick tocker I didn't actually
want to be too uh tough with him because
he's 18 and he's he thinks he's a
prankster
you know who knows how malevolent his
thinking really was he probably just
thought it was all a bit of a jabe he's
not got much of a deterrent today I mean
a 360 odd pound fine and if you do it
again you get a more tough sentence is
that the right message to send to kids
like this no but I think what he really
needs is a mentor or somebody to take
right in hand because look he he didn't
feel sincere in his apology no but he's
a clever smart lad he's got He's Got
Talent there I mean we want to harness
him because you can't have him going
around
causing trouble for families and it's
noticeable of an old woman he didn't
take it from a six foot two gym Bunny
with a with a rock he's not clever or
smart he's part of a narcissistic
generation that thinks they can do
whatever they want to be that's smart on
the internet with likes and tweets he
makes a very good case for bringing back
corporal punishment he was completely
not resourceful he was completely what
would happen if he'd pull this stunt all
these stunts in oh my gosh I was I was
actually in the green room with this one
we're like if you weren't gone
I mean there are lots of government in
America he'd be shocked right I mean and
that you know I mean that's I just felt
with him remember Rosanna yeah you then
said where's your mother I don't talk to
her he didn't mention her father he's
you just wonder who is there is his any
kind of moral compass I mean by the end
all he was doing was promoting his next
thing or whatever
um I sort of agree with Kevin to a
degree is that he's not an idiot I mean
I called him an idiot for his idiotic
Behavior but to actually do what he was
doing he's got some ability he just
harnesses it in completely the wrong way
right I mean how do you how do you
harness that and make him think that
there's a better way to make money and
to have a life at 18 unfortunately it
might be too late I'm watching it was it
was quite uncomfortable watching it
because I felt like he was about 14 or
15 but he is a legal adult as he said
himself but it's not tick tock's fault
as some people are saying you know we
need to regulate the social media
platforms but it is something to do with
attention the attention that these kids
needs and he was saying I don't care if
I'm liked or disliked I just know I want
to be talked about and that's something
you know well look I would be the last
person on Earth to condemn that
philosophy but I just think that what he
was doing is I'm like I again I agree
with you about the kind of things he was
doing it's a form of Terror that he was
doing yeah
um albeit I'm not entirely sure he
understood that and for him to play the
race card I'm so sorry I think that's
what incends me the most it's because
we've given people like this an Avenue
to just you know abuse the system right
you can't this is not a race issue and
if actually if he wasn't the part of the
world where they're majority of black
people he would never get away with this
because discipline is quite strict in
other parts nothing to do with his
skincare exactly no but he's not had the
easiest start
I'm sorry no excuse but it's an
explanation okay why is behaving and
it's why I somehow give him something
constructive in his life because he he
is he is talented yeah but you see you
see results Tick Tock isn't responsible
I'm not so sure about that these social
media companies they don't want to be
regulated like Publishers or
broadcasters they do allow their
platforms to be misused in this way this
kid was racking up loads of likes and
attention and Buzz and noise without
Tick Tock doing anything about it you
know when when you start terrorizing
going into people's homes and when
they've got young kids in there or
you're taking an old woman's dog that
shouldn't be allowed to be on a platform
where is the regulation of that contact
well it does raise the question this
kind of behavior has been happening for
forever with teenage you know
unfortunately pranksters you know bad
apples there's going to be people out
there it's just now that they can video
it and share it amongst themselves does
it encourage me well the other thing
that's going on of course are the just
stop oil protesters and we've got a
little lesson I think from our friends
in Germany about how to deal with these
people this is what they do over there
[Applause]
instant SWAT team right off you go
um
no mucking around I mean Esther again it
just seemed to me we are very
with these protesters when they're
genuinely causing Masters disruption to
people to go about their lives well it
completely undermines our faith in the
police and and and the people that are
around to protect us because they always
sort of break the boundaries between
actually protesting and then putting the
public at risk and the Germans
understand how to deal with these people
you can absolutely protest peacefully
but when you act when you get to the
point where you're gluing yourself to
the M25 for instance you're actually
posing a risk to the public and I think
that's what we're really struggling to
get right here in this country should we
go a bit more German yeah I wouldn't be
against it I believe in the the right to
protest but I also give you protests as
a right for the police to come and move
out the way because you've got to feel
for the frustration of people who are
driving going to work or going home
whatever they're doing ambulance yeah
when people just it's a hard question
though Rosanna because you know if you
go back and chart the history of say the
suffragettes yeah they did a lot of
public disorder disruption but they made
progress for that reason no no they did
and that's my point is like although I
find them very objectionable the way
they go about their business they would
argue with some Merit well we're only
doing what the suffragist did when they
wanted to get the vote what's the
difference they had to use disruptive
tactics and and disrupt the public to
get what they wanted a massive
existential issue you do have to do
something about it and oh Schwarzenegger
said it this week in an interview you
know he said the world there are people
around the world that are not happy the
way governments are dealing with the
climate crisis you're going to need a
form of activity here's the difference
the suffragettes were fighting for the
right to have right um rights that were
being deprived of them they're not being
deprived of anything that's the
difference these Justice oil protests
are wanting are wanting to take away
people's rights to basically use
whatever fossil fuels they want or for
for companies to produce fossil fuels
and all of that the suffragettes were
fighting for the right to get them
they're not being they're not being
deprived of anything they're trying to
deprive the public they're fighting for
our existential that's what they believe
existence
don't do this monks okay monks can argue
that actually we're going to go to
Oxford Street and Shout about how your
soul needs to be saved if you don't
become a buddy
why does that make that okay if they do
it yeah but why can't you campaign
against fossil fuels my heart is with
just stop
if you block roads or you jump on a
snooker table you're not going to win
public support
What if I
make me right yeah
quick word about Tina Turner yeah
because one of the all-time greats I
mean I don't think I've been to a party
in my life where some stage there hasn't
been a Tina Turner song yeah I mean
absolutely look at that she's a legend
she's so well known uh 83 years old
though and was fighting a long illness
so you know tragic tragic times indeed
but I don't think it's come as a great
surprise for him I was just talking to
one of the makeup artists for your show
and she said she has um worked with the
lady who plays Tina Turner on the west
end stage and she said Tienda looked
very well recently I saw in a restaurant
in south of France once and she just
walked in and the whole place stood up
I've not seen that very often it's an
amazing moment I've never heard anybody
who didn't like her the writer and
you're right the songs are just
fantastic
all the domestic violence that she
enjoyed the hands of her husband I that
also made her I think for a lot of women
an iconic figure and her grit absolutely
I mean she worked for two years I think
to pay off the debts that incurred from
the separation from it she worked at she
was on food stamps for two years she
worked in you know bars and you know
Jazz lounges incredible what a performer
yeah yeah when she did I mean she sang
Simply the Best for what she did Simply
the Best I mean really in terms of great
foot stomping you know rock star women I
think Tina Turner for me was number one
um Tokyo number one I'm off next week
and Rosanna you got the Short Straw you
are filling in for me again it's a bit
like you know trying to hold the fort
for Frank Sinatra in Vegas but you know
good luck I mean I'm sloshing around in
those big shoes I'm trying to feel yeah
well I appreciate you dude thank you
very much uh and thanks to my pack as
well I'm sensitive next Rhonda santis
formerly takes on Donald Trump as he
launches his bid for the White House
tonight in a an interview with Elon Musk
actually is going live on Twitter but
can he win the battle for the heart and
minds and success potentially of the
Republican Party we'll debate that next
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
thank you
coming off on the talk Boris Johnson
bites back following fresh accusations
he broke more lockdown rules and
France's ban on local flights fails to
take off and we're asking if King
Charles is living in the shadow of his
daughter-in-law Princess Catherine all
of that and more at nine
thank you
[Music]
well sorry to go to Rhonda santis is
finally announcing his long anticipated
2024 Republican Presidential bid tonight
is formally filed paperwork to confirm
his candidacity to launch his campaign
not on TV a conversation on Twitter with
its CEO Elon Musk
we'll be interviewing
um
Ron Santos and he has quite an
announcement to make
and we'll be we're first saying that
something like this is happening on
social media
well Donald Trump who launched his
second presidential bid in November last
year's repeatedly Trash Talk the
governor the former president as well
ahead in the polls at the moment but
this is the turning point to DeSantis in
the battle for the heart and soul of the
Republican Party joining me now's
best-selling author in colonies for the
southern New York Post Douglas Murray
and Fox Nation and outkick host Tommy
lahren okay Douglas Morris is really
interesting moment I think in this race
because the narrative so far Donald
Trump is unassailable as republican
nominees way ahead in the polls
and yet DeSantis has managed to be
polling in the mid-20s without actually
announcing he's been running how
significant is tonight going to be do
you think
I think it's very significant I mean
this is it they're off you know the the
Republican contenders have been holding
back all this time have finally started
to come out and the race is now on as
you say Peters I mean uh Trump is so far
ahead of the other candidates currently
among Republican uh voters that you may
say some people have that it's basically
an unassailable lead I don't think
that's inevitable as you say I mean
Rhonda Sanders is just about to start
his campaign from here on he will do all
the interviews he'll be questioned about
all of the things he hasn't yet had a
chance to talk about he'll be able to
talk up all of the policies and the the
successes he's had in Florida as
governor and talk about how he can roll
them out on the on on the national stage
so this is really the beginning of the
race there's one big conundrum for the
Republicans in this race which is
essentially the Republicans desperately
want Joe Biden to be the Democrat
nominee and the Democrats desperately
want Donald Trump to be the Republican
nominee uh almost all the polls show
that if Trump Trump goes against Biden
Trump loses but the question is as it
were what do you do about the Republican
primaries and that's the that's the
first thing to get through yeah I want
to play Tommy before I come to you just
a clip from my interview with Rhonda
santis last month down in Florida at the
governor Mansion quite interesting when
I asked him does he have what it takes
to be president
do you think you have what it takes to
be president of the United States look I
think what it takes is to have a vision
for the country uh have the ability to
exercise leadership and being willing to
stand in that fire when it gets really
really hot and and not back down under
pressure and I think I have all those
things
you think Tommy I think people
underestimate the scientists see this is
a guy who's a Harvard and Yale student
graduate he then went and became a
special counsel legal counsel to the
commander of sealed team one in Fallujah
for a year in Iraq during the worst year
for the war for the Americans so this is
a guy who understands the heat of battle
quite literally what do you make of him
as a candidate
I think he's going to be an excellent
candidate and again if we were talking
about this race without the trump card
in it so to speak I think it would be a
very different discussion but he's going
to have a big battle ahead and
unfortunately it's not going to be
really battling the left or battling the
Democrats that's something I think he
could do with ease it's going to be
battling Donald Trump and making sure
that while he takes on Donald Trump he
doesn't offend the flock of trump
supporters that want Trump only want
Trump they're always going to be loyal
to Trump we've put ourselves in an
interesting position here where we may
very well nominate somebody to our
ticket that cannot win a general
election out of loyalty alone and that's
something that the GOP is going to have
to Grapple with and decide if loyalty is
more important than winning the White
House I don't think it is and I say that
as a trump supporter I think that's an
excellent point you know I think that
this is the as you said Douglas the
conundrum facing it let me ask you a
hypothetical should Ron DeSantis win the
nomination could you ever imagine Trump
then playing the kind of role of King
maker where he gets behind him to win
the national election or do you think
Trump would behave as I would expect
Trump to behave and run off and throw
his toys out of the pram and try and run
as an independent or something crazy
I I was talking about this with somebody
earlier today and I said if you can can
you imagine somebody anybody less likely
to put the interests of their party
ahead of themselves than Donald J Trump
I mean at any point uh uh where he
thinks he might lose when it when that
comes in when that realization comes to
him perhaps he might realize that you
know he doesn't want to be a two-time
loser I mean here's a question I would
ask Trump if I had the opportunity which
is you know given that you still claim
that 2020 was rigged what do you think
is different in 2024 hello what are you
doing about it what have you done yeah
and the answer as usual is nothing yeah
so so so for Trump there is obviously
that you know going to be some point to
which you'll have to work out you know
do I want to be a loser twice around or
do I want to present myself as having
the ability to win but have chosen not
to go forward at some point this time I
just don't see him ever dropping out of
this race without trying to destroy the
Republican Party along with him I I'm
afraid I share that fear actually if I
was a republican voter I would be
thinking quite hard about that let me
ask you Tommy another hypothetical
should Ron DeSantis win the nomination
it's going to be tough for him he's
going to take down Trump but if he does
and I wouldn't underestimate him at all
from my experience of of time with him
could you see the Democrats then
creating some health problem with Joe
Biden that means he can't run against
somebody literally half his age with
three times energy and dynamism and they
then parachute somebody in like Gavin
Newsom say the the young Californian
Governor could you see that hypothetical
happening
foreign
yeah I don't just see it happening I
think that is exactly what is going to
happen if Ron DeSantis is our nominee I
think the Biden Camp thinks that they
can hide Joe in the basement yet again
and beat Donald Trump because they're
going after Donald Trump with the media
the legal system I mean you name it
they're throwing everything in the
kitchen sink at Donald Trump so I think
that they feel rather comfortable
running against Trump even if everything
is in disarray quite literally in this
country but Ron DeSantis oh I don't
think so I think exactly what you just
said is going to happen it's going to be
Joe is going to step down due to his age
they're going to bring Gavin Newsom in I
guarantee you that is going to be the
pathway if Rhonda Santos is our nominee
they will not take that chance of
running Joe Biden against Rhonda okay I
want two names from both of you Douglas
I want to know who's going to win the
Republican nomination and who's going to
win the 2024 election give me two names
uh currently it'll be Donald Trump
getting the Republican nomination and
Joe Biden being president if it happens
the other way around by the way if it
becomes the Santa's uh Mrs Newson that
is a real election it is that is the
success of Florida versus the
catastrophe of California
give me two names Republican nomination
and the winner of the 2024.
all right I'm gonna be optimistic I do
think that Trump is going to end up
being our nominee and I'm gonna tell you
I think he's going to win against Joe
Biden because I think this party is
going to do it
so I think he's going to be Trump Biden
and I think I'm going to leave it
Douglas Tommy thank you both very much
indeed tomorrow night a special program
artificial intelligence what do we know
how dangerous I've got big brains to
debate a big topic that's tomorrow night
Keep It Uncensored good night
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored